[Aplausos]
[Música]
kazajistán es la clásica dictadura ex
soviética un país tristemente conocido
por la película borat No solo eso a
principios de este año 2022 Vladimir
Putin envió tropas para ayudar a
mantener el régimen tras unas protestas
que lo pusieron en jaque a priori
parecería un país absolutamente Leal al
kremlin verdad sin embargo cuando en la
ONU Se abordó la invasión de Ucrania
llegó la sorpresa
[Música]
tan solo cuatro países aparte de Rusia
votaron en contra de condenar la
invasión de Ucrania entre los fieles a
Putin encontramos a la Bielorrusia de
lukashenko la Corea del Norte de la
serie de basadas de Isaías vamos lo
mejor de cada casa pero ni rastro de la
kazajistán te toca Jeff que optó por
abstenerse
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando mucho
saber Fonseca Pero en serio A quién le
importa la ONU aparte de kofiana banki
Moon y el portugués ese que está ahora
que no le conoce ni en su casa a la hora
de comer pues sí tenéis razón pero es
que en junio en San Petersburgo en las
mismísimas narices de Putin el
presidente toca Jeff dijo esto
como os podéis imaginar esto para Rusia
es una puñalada trapera en toda regla
una posición que también es complicada
para cada instante porque por mucho casi
petróleo que tengan por mucho que
kazajistán sea el dubái de la estepa su
economía está completamente integrada
con la rusa
[Música]
y de hecho por el territorio ruso
circula todo el petróleo kazajo que
llega a la Unión Europea para que os
hagáis una idea un 6% del petróleo que
importan los 27 países de la Unión
Europea procede de kazajistán Así que la
pregunta es por qué kazajistán traiciona
Rusia Cómo puede afectar todo esto a la
Unión Europea y en general a Europa hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes Europa Como ya sabéis tiene miedo
de quedarse oscuras el 40% de todo el
gas que se consume procede de la madre
Rusia y ahora el kremlin ha cerrado el
Grifo y no sabemos exactamente si lo va
a abrir o cuando lo va a hacer para
colmo la demanda de energía en el mundo
no deja de crecer Durante las próximas
tres décadas la población mundial
crecerá atentos en cerca de 2.500
millones de personas y además las
economías emergentes están acelerando su
convergencia en Consumo con los países
más ricos en otras palabras que vamos a
necesitar Sí o sí nuevas fuentes de
energía y a gran escala Así que la
pregunta es de dónde saldrá energía Qué
cambios veremos Durante las próximas
décadas en el mix energético de los
países Cómo esperan las economías
europeas librarse de su dependencia de
la energía rusa si quieres conocer todas
las respuestas a estas preguntas No te
pierdas el último vídeo de si lo
hubieras sabido como sabéis si lo
hubiera sabido es el canal de
información financiera demuto activos
con el que participamos os dejo el
enlace en la descripción y ahora sí
vamos a ver un poco de historia
la Nevada soviética
[Música]
si hay un país que ha sufrido las
consecuencias de estar en la unión
soviética Ese es kazajistán aquí en
visualpolitik siempre hemos dicho que la
unión soviética fue un imperio colonial
en toda regla y los pobres kazajos lo
sufrieron más que pocos queréis un
ejemplo pues os doy un ejemplo la bomba
atómica habéis oído bien pero esperad un
momento todos sabemos que la bomba
atómica es una auténtica salvajada Pero
qué os parecería hacer pruebas nucleares
en tus propios ciudadanos suena
auténtica locura verdad
[Música]
pues esto es lo que sufrieron los pobres
kazajos que vivían en la ciudad de
kurchatov junto a la cual se encontraba
el sitio de pruebas de semipalatinsk la
principal instalación de pruebas
nucleares de la antigua Unión soviética
o también la población de ese mei una
ciudad situada a 150 kilómetros del
lugar de las pruebas la lección de esta
zona por la parte de veria El
lugarteniente más desviado de stalin
tenían objetivo premeditado estudiar los
efectos de la radiación en el cuerpo
humano por eso los soviéticos realizaron
ensayos de bombas nucleares cerca de
estas dos poblaciones habitadas de hecho
Las investigaciones más importantes en
este ámbito se han efectuado en
kazajistán es uno de los pocos lugares
del mundo donde hay casos reales de
humanos que han sufrido este tipo de
radiaciones
Por cierto que si queréis conocer todos
los detalles de esta historia en nuestro
canal hermano en mega projects con cada
visualpolitik vamos a sacar un vídeo
donde contamos toda esta historia por
supuesto No toda la influencia soviética
fue mala por ejemplo en kazajistán
también es donde está el famoso
cosmodromo de kazajistán Rusia seguirá
usando baikonur hasta al menos 2050 y ya
sé lo que todos os estaréis preguntando
ahora a ver Fonseca pero aparte de
bombas nucleares y cohetes espaciales
que más hicieron los soviéticos por los
kazajos pues bueno ya desde un principio
la unión soviética procedió a convertir
a los kazajos que era un pueblo nómada
en campesinos para las nuevas granjas
colectivizadas
[Música]
el resultado fue letal las hambrunas en
los años 30 se cobraron la vida de
millón y medio de kazajos una cuarta
parte de toda la población pero en el
kremlin sabían Cómo repoblar el país las
pulgas estaban a la orden del día en la
unión soviética kazajistán fue junto a
Siberia uno de los principales destinos
para el exilio de los ciudadanos
molestos para el poder soviético por
otro lado el desplazamiento forzoso de
rusos también contribuyó a la
rusificación de kazajistán Donde la
etnia rusa fue mayoritaria durante más
de medio siglo hasta los años de mijail
gorbachov
de nuevo la lógica de la unión soviética
fue la misma que la de cualquier otro
imperio colonial para Moscú kazajistán
era un país gigantesco en el que
desarrollar sus planes agrícolas para
convertir sus pastos en una región
productora de cereales para la unión
soviética y allí desplazaron a un montón
de población rusa para copar las élites
políticas económicas y sociales de la
República socialista soviética kazaja
de hecho todavía hoy en día el ruso
sigue siendo lengua cooficial del estado
junto al propio kazajo Y eso explica que
los kazajos no tengan demasiado
cariñosos antiguos colonizadores de
hecho ya empezamos a ver señales desde
rusificación los kazajos volverán al
alfabeto latino y abandonarán el
cirílico en 2023 pero esperad un momento
porque esto es tan solo la punta del
iceberg del resquemor que genera todo lo
que huele a Rusia entre los buenos
kazajos y muchos estaréis pensando vale
No será para tanto si aún están así y
han pasado más de 30 años desde la
independencia de kazajistán Pero hay dos
detalles que no debemos perder de vista
primer lugar desde el año 1990 el poder
los tentó nursultan nazarballev Es decir
desde un año antes de que kazajistán se
independizara de la unión soviética Así
que como os podéis imaginar el principal
interesado en que se produjeran pocos
cambios era el propio presidente la
principal transformación con nacer
vallés llegó con la apertura la
inversión extranjera para explotar los
enormes recursos naturales de kazajistán
y diréis de Qué recursos naturales
hablamos Pues básicamente de sus campos
de petróleo y de sus campos de gas
natural el segundo detalle que tenemos
que tener en cuenta es que la economía
cazaga estaba muy integrada con la rusa
por lo que podríamos decir que estaban
condenados a entenderse cuando Rusia
estornuda nosotros nos resfriamos dicho
kazajo con este panorama los kazajos son
unos días prorrusos y otros días
antirrusos Por supuesto Rusia siempre ha
hecho todo lo posible para tenerlos Bajo
su órbita
ahí se marca por ejemplo la unión
económica euroasiática de la que ya
hemos hablado varias veces en
visualpolitik y que como sabéis es una
organización impulsada por Vladimir
Putin para sostener esa influencia rusa
sobre Asa central cuando se puso en
marcha en 2015 kazajistán tenía un buen
motivo para actuar con cautela una
cuarta parte de su población es de etnia
rusa y Putin había utilizado ya un
pretexto similar para anexar crimea en
Ucrania Así que kazajistán aceptó unirse
a la uee priorizando su vertiente
económica y bloqueando todas las
sugerencias rusas para adoptar a la
organización de competencias políticas y
de defensa de este modo los kazajos han
buscado tener su propia voz en el mundo
y no depender en ningún caso de Rusia
Pero claro todo esto estaba muy bien
Hasta que llegaron las revueltas de
enero de 2022 y ahí es cuando toca Jeff
el nuevo presidente de kazajistán desde
el año 2019 se vio entre la espada y la
pared el presidente kazajo Busca ayuda
del bloque de seguridad liderado por
Rusia desde luego esta intervención fue
para Rusia la gran oportunidad para
poderse meter de nuevo en los asuntos de
kazajistán está claro que el presidente
toca Jeff miró a todos los lados y como
os podéis imaginar Pues la verdad es que
ni Estados Unidos ni en la Unión Europea
iban a ayudar a apuntar a una dictadura
Así que no le quedó otra que utilizar el
comodín Putin A qué precio al de una
lealtad absoluta pues atentos
tú también bruto hijo mío
tras la intervención de las tropas rusas
para afianzar a tocayaba en el poder que
por cierto lo cubrimos ya en
visualpolitik parecía que las relaciones
entre kazajistán y Rusia eran más
próximas que nunca Y entonces es cuando
llega la invasión de Ucrania y cuando se
supone que Putin que llevaba años
trabajando en Asia central para
construir un bloque regional liderado
por Rusia esperaba que todos estos
países lo apoyaran sin embargo y aquí es
cuando viene la parte interesante la
repúblicas están los famosos instantes
han estado en silencio durante toda la
Guerra de Ucrania y no solo eso es que
encima Putin se ha encontrado con que
toca Jeff le ha salido respondón Mirad
Cómo respira la prensa rusa esto es una
puñalada por la espalda las redes están
indignadas por el nombramiento de un
rusófobo como ministro de información en
kazajistán
[Música]
el rumbo trazado por tocayef después de
la intervención de las tropas rusas
demuestra que el presidente kazajo
desconfía completamente de Putin O mejor
dicho que no quiere de ninguna forma ser
visto como un títere de Moscú y por eso
desde que volvió a sentirse segura en el
poder toca Jeff está protagonizando un
montón de gestos contra la influencia
rusa al mismo tiempo también está
terminando con todo lo que huele al
antiguo presidente nazar vallés Por qué
Pues para consolidar por un lado su
imagen de independiente y porque por
otro lado era el entorno del
expresidente quien tenía más lazos con
el kremlin O al menos Esa era la imagen
que ahora quiere dar toca Jeff y por eso
en cuanto pudo le convirtió en el chivo
expiatorio
[Música]
entre otras cosas le ha retirado todos
los honores que aún nos tentaba Como por
ejemplo la presidencia del comité de
seguridad nacional también ha destituido
a su hija dariga nazarballeva que llegó
a ser presidenta del senado y ya no es
ni siquiera parlamentaria ya sabéis la
política en estos países siempre queda
en familia Pero atentos porque toca Jeff
no se ha quedado ahí kazajistán los
compinches clave de nazarballev padecen
una aparente purga el sobrino del
expresidente ha sido despedido como jefe
adjunto de los poderosos servicios de
seguridad y ya sé lo que os estaréis
preguntando Pero y todo esto por qué
pues según parece esto que ayer cree que
todos esos graves disturbios del pasado
enero obedecen a intereses de algunos
sectores próximos al ex presidente nazar
ballé para que el gobierno kazajo le
abriera de nuevo la puerta del país al
kremlin Y sí toca Jeff le dio las llaves
de kazajistán a Putin Pero en cuanto a
las tropas rusas se marcharon lo primero
que hizo fue cambiar la cerradura
[Música]
toca Jeff no está marcando diferencias
con el kremlin porque sea precisamente
un amante de la Democracia sino por una
cuestión de soberanía en Ucrania toca
Jeff está viendo lo que Rusia es capaz
de hacer con una antigua República
soviética una invasión amenazaría
directamente al pueblo kazajo pero
también supondría una amenaza para su
poder en Bielorrusia toca Jeff está
viendo que apoyar a Rusia supondría dar
Carta blanca al kremlin para abusar de
la soberanía kazaja
vamos a decirlo claro ahora mismo si
Putin toca la balalaika lukasenko Baila
como un cosaco y claro nadie quiere ser
El títere de nadie mucho menos un
dictador Así que al no apoyar a Rusia el
líder kazajo también es consciente de
que está ganando puntos con occidente y
el respaldo occidental ojo ojo porque
ese respaldo occidental le puede venir
muy bien a tocajez para sostener el
pulso que está echando a las antiguas
élites katajas que aún controlan azar
Vallejo el anterior dictador el problema
el problema para kazajistán es que como
os podéis imaginar Putin no está
dispuesto a quedarse con las manos
quietas mientras les desafían atentos
Rusia cierra la terminal petrolera de
novorosis después de que kazajistán se
ofreciera enviar más petróleo a la Unión
Europea el puerto ruso de no Roses es la
vía de salida que utiliza kazajistán
para exportar el 80% de su petróleo
el consorcio del oleducto del caspio que
gestiona esta macrotubería de 1500
kilómetros desde los yacimientos catajos
hasta el mar Negro consiguió en julio
que la terminal rusa volviera a operar
aún así cada dos por tres estiloductos
está viendo interrumpido Por quién Pues
evidentemente por Rusia y como os podéis
imaginar todo esto está afectando a la
economía kazaja la economía de
kazajistán se ralentiza por la guerra de
Rusia las previsiones de producción de
petróleo se han recortado en medio de
las dificultades para utilizar un
oleoducto clave para que os hagáis una
idea kazajistán redujo a la mitad su
previsión de crecimiento económico para
este año del 4% al 2%, pero esperad un
momento mis queridos amigos y amigas de
visualpolitik porque también Europa
puede verse perjudicadas y Rusia vuelve
a cerrar los grifos al petróleo kazajo
por eso la Unión Europea y kazajistán
están trabajando en alternativas para
evitar a Rusia y diréis como pueden
hacerlo Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
estás vidania Putin
solo hay una noticia que este verano se
ha repetido en Europa tanto como las
olas de calor La amenaza continua de
Putin de dejarnos sin energía se acerca
el invierno y el kremlin ya ha cortado
todo el gas que va por el norte
estrimuno y no se sabe muy bien cuando
lo va a reanudar si es que va a hacerlo
como os podéis imaginar todo esto sirve
para que la Unión Europea se lo piense
dos veces antes de seguir apoyando a
celenski y en medio de todo esto se está
viendo a kazajistán cada vez que Rusia
impide que su petróleo llegue al mar
Negro camino de exportación hacia Europa
y por este motivo en julio de 2022
comenzaron las conversaciones al más
alto nivel entre kazajistán y la Unión
Europea y toca ayer tiene claro lo que
hay que hacer atentos el presidente de
kazajistán pide nuevas rutas de
exportación de petróleo después de que
Rusia suspendiera un oleducto clave toca
Jeff aspira construir un oleoducto bajo
en mar caspio que conecte ambas orillas
no es el único país en la zona
interesado en construir una tubería para
exportar sus recursos energéticos hacia
el mercado europeo turkmenistán también
quiere hacer negocio con su gas
[Música]
el futuro digamos proyectos por la otra
orilla del caspio pasa por azerbaiyán
pero no quiero daros más detalles sobre
este asunto porque va a ser materia de
un próximo vídeo el problema para
kazajistán es que un óleoducto
transcaspiano no es algo que se puede
hacer de la noche a la mañana
especialmente teniendo en cuenta que va
por debajo del mar Tito called quiere
soluciones ya de momento los kazajos han
encontrado una fórmula que Bueno les
puede valer pero por una temporada
exclusiva kazajistán comenzará las
ventas de petróleo a través del
oleoducto aceri para evitar a Rusia
desde este mes de septiembre de 2022
kazajistán ha comenzado a utilizar una
flota de Pequeños petroleros para llevar
su zumo de dinosaurio a través del mar
caspio hasta bakú allí utilizará el
oleducto btc que conecta bakú TV Lisi la
capital de Georgia y feijan una ciudad
turca en la costa mediterránea La idea
es complementar esta vía en 2023
aprovechando otro gasoducto que parte de
azerbaiyán para llegar a subsa un puerto
de Georgia en el mar Negro ahora bien es
esto definitiva pues no ni de broma
es insuficiente se estima que utilizando
estas vías cada ciclistan podría dar
salida a unos 100.000 barriles de
petróleo diarios apenas un 8%, si lo
comparamos con lo que envía o lo que
enviaba a través de Rusia podría ser
algo más si se añade otra opción que
también se está valorando en kazajistán
que es enviar el petróleo por
ferrocarril hasta batumi otro puerto de
Georgia que está en el mar Negro pero
esta vía también atravesaría territorio
ruso Así que en general estamos hablando
de Pequeños parches para garantizar que
el petróleo kazajo siga llegando a
Europa aunque sea con cuentagotas sin
embargo mi querida comunidad de
visualpolitik todo esto podría ser el
comienzo de algo más importante una
señal de que cada gestán quiere dejar de
depender de una vez por todas de Rusia y
eso es un cambio muy importante en Asia
central Mientras tanto toca Jeff no
pierde el tiempo atentos el líder de
kazajistán Busca elecciones anticipadas
y reducir el mandato presidencial
seguramente las elecciones kazaga
seguirán siendo el mismo teatro de
siempre no tendrían que celebrarse hasta
el año 2024 pero toca Jeff las quiere
adelantar a este otoño antes Espera que
el parlamento kazajo apruebe un cambio
muy relevante que cambió es limitar los
mandatos presidenciales a uno único de 7
años toca Jeff tiene ya 69 años y no
puede aspirar a marcar una nueva era en
kazajistán pero en los próximos siete
años tiene la oportunidad de cambiar
kazajistán más que durante las tres
décadas de nacer vallés y todo esto
puede tener consecuencias muy
importantes para Europa Así que ojo
porque aquí en visualpolitik que vamos a
estar atentos pero mientras tanto La
pregunta es para vosotros conseguirá
kazajistán reducir su dependencia de
Rusia o llegaremos a ver un
enfrentamiento directo entre Putin y
toca Jeff qué intereses puede tener la
Unión Europea en kazajistán podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y mientras tanto no olvidéis
que aquí en visualpolitik sacamos vídeos
nuevos Todas las semanas así que
suscribíos a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]